good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp
1984
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
scp-1984 is to be secured at armed
containment complex four
kilometers south-southeast of virkoyansk
saka republic russian federation mobile
task force omega-59
nicholas wolves and mobile task force
sigma 18
chess masters are to be permanently
stationed at complex 4.
scp-1984 itself is to be contained in
warehouse 5e in a standard humanoid
containment cell modified to be enclosed
within a faraday cage to prevent
external broadcasts from reaching the
interior the only broadcasts allowed to
reach scp-1984
are those created by the information
control team all broadcast signals in
the vicinity of complex 4 are to be
monitored
at all times the information control
team shall be staffed with no fewer than
15 members and housed in dormitory 3f
adjacent to studio 1a among these must
be at least one military historian two
personnel with extensive background in
international diplomacy one economist
two actors with significant stage
experience and three personnel with at
least 10 years of experience in the
soviet russian media
scp-1984 is to receive a narrative
transmitted via radio and television
broadcasts depicting an ongoing state of
daeton between the soviet union and nato
designed to resemble official releases
from tass the associated press the bbc
and other established cold war era news
organizations
description
scp-1984 was created by the soviet union
during the 1980s to serve as its second
strike nuclear deterrence mechanism
scp-1984 is in fact the system referred
to in western media as
dead hand an automated nuclear response
commonly believed to be triggered by the
destruction of the soviet command and
control structure however rather than
being a network of sensors and computing
systems
scp-1984 is an autonomous self-aware
entity of varying observable existence
with direct access to russian nuclear
sites and the ability to commence the
launch of icbms stored therein
scp-1984 consists of the embalmed
remains of sergeant marat chernikov a
russian soldier killed during the soviet
afghan war in 1982 while sergeant
turnakov is referenced in project
december documentation no official
russian federation records exist
regarding him at this time
scp-1984 serves as the locus for
scp-1984-01
in its dormant state scp-198401
is a semi-sentient consciousness capable
of receiving and processing broadcast
signals scp-198401
can apparently discern the informational
content of any broadcast it receives
during times of what it perceives to be
heightened global military tensions
especially those involving the russian
federation and the former satellite
states of the soviet union
scp-1984-01 will begin to manifest and
becomes able to interact with the
physical world to varying degrees
manifestations have ranged from a barely
perceptible hazy human-shaped outline
believed to be related to an
unintercepted report regarding the 2004
russian presidential election to a
glowing bright red apparition in the
distended shape of a child missing its
legs containment breach 1984-13
0807 2008.
when
scp-1984-1 manifests in this manner its
secondary abilities become apparent
these include the ability to directly
interface with nuclear command systems
within an approximately 50 meter radius
and combat capabilities focused on
severe disruption of the human nervous
system when scp-1984
fully manifests it can move at speeds
measured up to 140 kilometers per hour
and will immediately attempt to travel
to the nearest functioning land-based
strategic rocket installation housing
r36m icbms the nearest installation is
currently
81 kilometers northwest of armed
containment complex 4. access its
command system and launch all missiles
at their present targets it will repeat
this process until it has launched all
remaining missiles under russian control
scp-198401
is extremely hostile to any human it
perceives as interfering with it and
will engage any personnel in its
immediate path
scp-1984-1 has shown limited
vulnerability to microwave radiation
however
this serves to misdirect and confuse the
entity rather than directly harm it
recovery log in 1984.
in early 1984 dr sergey
the soviet union's official liaison with
the foundation contacted ophi
overseer of eurasian affairs at the time
to discuss what was characterized as a
matter of grave importance to the
continued survival of the human race at
a secret conference in sarajevo
yugoslavia coinciding with the 1984
winter olympics to provide cover for the
presence of high-ranking state officials
from several nations
soviet and united states officials
briefed overwatch command on the true
nature of dead hand then assumed by the
foundation to be a traditional nuclear
deterrent and the existence of scp-1984
in the wake of information obtained by
soviet officials after the suicide of dr
anatoly lavrentiev and the subsequent
destruction of his research facility
scp-1984 was revealed to be both
increasingly beyond the control of the
soviet government and designed outside
of original specifications
rather than serving as an assured second
strike nuclear response in the event of
the complete destruction of soviet
leadership
scp-1984-1 was actively attempting to
initiate a nuclear first strike at
targets in the united states france west
germany
and the people's republic of china at
the request of a joint u.s soviet
delegation the foundation agreed to
assume control of scp-1984
and immediately commence containment
procedures dr
a surviving senior researcher with
project december and codenamed ezra by
the foundation was appointed as director
of armed containment complex iv
incident report 1984 won
on 08 11 1984 united states president
ronald reagan joked that i'm pleased to
tell you today that i've signed
legislation that will outlaw russia
forever we begin bombing in five minutes
prior to a campaign speech thousands of
media outlets reported on the
president's remarks
and in the ensuing signal traffic an
audio recording of the event broadcast
by the people's republic of china's
genuine news agency reached scp-1984
researchers note we still do not
understand how transmissions are able to
occasionally bypass the faraday
structure in closing 1984. studies are
ongoing
upon receiving the transmission
scp-198401 immediately underwent a full
manifestation event with no detectable
warning signs
scp-1984-01 breached containment at
0-308 hours and was immediately engaged
by mobile task force sigma-18 upon
citing mobile task force operatives
scp-198401
assumed the form of a blue translucent
emaciated woman dressed in traditional
pashtun attire and began attacking
according to video logs private
and captain
began exhibiting signs of neurological
trauma such as profuse bleeding from the
ears
seizures and leakage of copious amounts
of what appeared to be cerebrospinal
fluid from the nose and eyes before team
members equipped with specialized
weaponry could train directed microwave
pulses at scp-1984-1
holding it temporarily at bay
while mobile task force sigma 18
attempted to neutralize scp-1984-01
members of the information control team
hastily began recording a simulated
television broadcast designed to return
it to a dormant state the first attempt
video log 1984 84.42
was interrupted by the sound of a wall
collapsing 80 meters away the result of
a failed attempt by mobile task force
sigma-18 members to initiate emergency
protocol 12. the second attempt
succeeded although footage had to be
edited to remove one broadcaster who
began suffering what appeared to be a
stroke the resulting broadcast consisted
of a staged bbc news update stating that
the politburo had been in on the joke
and previously recorded contingency
footage of general secretary constantin
cernenko explicitly stating that the
soviet nuclear forces were not on
heightened alert
fighting between scp-198401
and mobile task force sigma 18 continued
for approximately 15 minutes after the
information control team broadcast its
report however scp-1984-1
soon began to fade and its attacks
decreased in intensity until containment
was re-established at 0.541 hours with
13 mobile task force operatives killed
in action
four support staff dead and eight more
staff rendered permanently disabled by
traumatic brain injuries
incident 1984 1 remains the deadliest
containment breach yet recorded for
scp-1984
recovered project december documentation
head research's note the following
documents are fragments recovered from
the destroyed laboratory of dr anatoly
lavrentiev director of project december
the vast majority of information from
this facility was lost and most
documents recovered have sustained heavy
fire or water damage this archive was
provided by the soviet government upon
transfer of custody of scp-1984
and the appointment of ezra as site
director because of the secrecy of
project december and dr lavrentiev's
triggering of numerous fail-safe
measures prior to his suicide
these documents are the only source of
direct information on scp-1984
besides ezra documents translated from
the original russian into english by
researchers
fragment 2c
suspected to be a memorandum from dr
lavrentiev to an unknown high-ranking
soviet military official date unknown
but assumed to be from between 1980 to
1981
due respect the game theorists beloved
idea of a second strike mechanism is
just as ignorant as the comrades they
criticize you will find one man out of a
thousand who will push the button that
wins the war not many will want the
blood of millions on their hands but
some will do it to ensure an end to the
conflict
this they use to justify themselves
but how many men will push the button
after the bombs have fallen how many
will sign the death warrant of the human
race and finish off what survivors that
may be left the threat may serve to keep
us safe but the act is only within the
mind of an unreachable madman perimeter
may be automated but it still must be
initiated by a human and not one of us
is capable of ending the world merely
for the sake
of ending it the solution then becomes
obvious
and fragment
fragment 12w
notes found in a charred binder that are
not consistent with other materials
recovered written in english original
source of document unknown several
unintelligible handwritten notes in what
is presumably russian are present in the
margins
at which point dr clark distributed
files to each of the members present
inside each file with the same contents
a photograph of a man in his late 50s
with receding gray hair
spectacles a mustache and a kind
grandfatherly expression photographs of
a typical suburban three-bedroom house
type written notes depicting a short
personal history of mr smith and a short
story written by dr clark about mr
smith's untimely end in an auto accident
ladies and gentlemen you know of course
that the person in your files is not
actually mr smith but a random citizen
unknown to each of you the real mr smith
like our construct is also deceased
which of course helps with any
troublesome legal action down the road
the information before you is a focal
point you must spend the next several
days familiarizing yourself with this
material
keep reading and reading until you are
convinced that mr smith is real this is
vital to establishing the correct
baseline for our eeg monitors when we
attempt to
lock twice for yes all assembled at the
table clearly indicated that they heard
two successive knocks seemingly
emanating from the center later
examinations of video records do not
display any evidence of movement among
any of the seated participants dr clark
moved on to the next question on the
seemingly the entity demonstrated
knowledge of information supplied to
participants as well as the details of
the life of mr
these properties first became known
after supplying participants with a
regimen of 8a pdhq desiccane
he then remarked that in light of miss
lamaliere's injuries that he was glad
that we hadn't imagined a hostile figure
this one was bad enough thanks
end fragment
fragment 21 x
document consistent with personnel
reports kept by kgb administration date
unknown but assumed to be prior to 1982.
sergeant chernikov has been noted by
commanding officers to suffer from
periodic episodes of what appeared to be
migraines however he has never sought
medical attention whether this is
related to the events in krasnodar is
unclear but in any event the
investigation could not determine
sergeant chernikov's exact role in the
death of private bectorev exoneration
notwithstanding sergeant chernikov has
repeatedly demonstrated anti-social
behavioral traits
unprovoked aggression against fellow
unit members and actions in the field
that border on psychotic efforts to
prevent knowledge and subsequent
propagandization of sergeant chernikov's
actions in the village of mangual far
outweigh the strategic benefit
originally sought by deployment of
veipel it is the opinion of this
commission that despite the critical
need for experienced personnel in
afghanistan sergeant chernikov be
removed from active duty and placed in
psychiatric care we can ill afford such
an unpredictable operative in such
sensitive mission areas
end fragment
fragment 29 b
excerpts from the diary of dr lavrentiev
march 21st 1981 researchers continuing
to act edgy and insolent many resent
being transferred to this project
enough it's not the goal we're trying to
accomplish that bothers them it's the
means we're employing to get there many
of them scoff at
magic and ghosts as they term it and
deride the workers unscientific
i know they call me rasputin behind my
back it was a mistake to inform them of
the whole picture
june 19th 1981 new research team arrived
today quickly divided up personnel into
teams each focusing on a piece of the
whole
most of the work will be able to be
explained under the auspices of direct
mind interface software neurological
research and observation of mass
psychological suggestion
i can finesse the rest
much better outlook
july 13th 1981 the tests have been in
line with what agent parks observed in
toronto the question now is what happens
when we recreate them on a large scale
and with a suitable focus
i shall inform the kgb liaison to begin
looking for personnel that fall within
our parameters
october 29 1981
finally installed phase two personnel i
hate to use yuri's connections but the
project must go forward and i couldn't
very well tell the committees to hurry
up with my ghost squad
november 5th 1981 initial success made
us too optimistic
when we ran the entity through a trial
launch sequence
it refused clearly it knew how because
instead it disabled the mock launch
terminal never considered what would
happen if our creation wouldn't
cooperate
i can't believe how stupid i've been
what the hell do i do now
december 13th
1981 the politburo has gotten involved
while this means my missing staff has
been replaced
and funds are no longer a question
bad things happen when scrutiny comes
from on high orders are to spare no
effort or expense to move forward moscow
sent a man who looked like a cossack to
deal with
alexi i was told to take a vacation for
a week when i returned to both alexi and
the cossack
were gone
december 24 1981 new test subject
provided by kgb liaison before i
specified loyalty as a defining
characteristic
this time i ask
need someone something who can be
trusted to activate and carry out
perimeter golovkin appears to have been
enough of a thug to do what a lexi
couldn't
february 11th 1982 this isn't working
even in simulations maybe they're closer
to understanding the real consequences
attached to the symbolic actions they do
politburo getting impatient
february 27th 1982
new candidate identified a spedsnaz
operative with undifferentiated cruelty
to others
promising
march 3rd
1982 we relied too much on pre-existing
character traits this time we will need
to
shall ensure that it will want to do it
once it's set loose
end fragment
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to tomothy
anvil
zargaron professor puffer
nobody
will rimmer
vino
gevios the hollow
zazipan
jordan c wilde
k
dr briggs
tailored printers
segnar
aletreon
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
lost boy
a real american hebrew
the morrigan
james sabha
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you